the kovid lockdowns in the united
kingdom are
just the tip of the iceberg in that
country for a broader religious conflict
and you've seen this
break out into the open just this this
week
a pastor in the united kingdom who is a
chaplain at a college there
he was a former chaplain at cambridge
university
this chaplain was fired not only fired
but reported to a terror watch agency of
the uk
government because he gave a sermon
defending the christian view of sex
take a listen it was just so
mind-blowing
i was thinking i'm never going to work
again
because i've been accused of being a
terrorist this is the sermon
i gave in june 2018
but remember that religious belief is
just as protected in law as sexual
orientation
and no one has the right to discriminate
against you or be abusive towards you
when ideologies compete we should not
descend into abuse
we should respect the beliefs of others
the fact that in
this day and age a sermon should be
deemed
effectively blasphemous by other people
it would just never have occurred to me
before this happened
that that could be something that would
happen in in 21st century britain which
i thought was a liberal
tolerant society so this guy obviously a
thoughtful guy
you know obviously very respectful guy a
very mild-mannered british guy it
reminds me of that scene in european
vacation
where chevy chase keeps running into the
the english bicyclist on his
in his car and the bicyclist keeps
apologizing to him
it's like oh we're so sorry yes yes well
no oh yes no it's all right no no no
just a little scratch yes yeah you know
any uh so the brits very very nice
people this guy very genial and now he's
being called a terrorist
but what he doesn't understand is that
last line there at the end he said
i can't believe that in 21st century
england which i thought was a respectful
tolerant liberal society i can't believe
that
my views of christianity would be called
blasphemy
that's because this fellow doesn't seem
to understand that
liberalism is a jealous god
liberalism is a very jealous god and
uh people who practice
their religion out in the open they
tend to have a more coherent view of the
world they tend to be more grounded
there's this idea that religious people
are very superstitious
no we're actually the least
superstitious people on earth because we
know exactly what we think and we're
subjecting it to rigor
the people who pretend not to have a
religion they tend to be the kookiest
they tend to be
the most superstitious they tend to be
the most censorious
because they're not even aware of what
they're doing liberalism is a jealous
god here's what this guy did
he's at trent college which by the way
purports to have a christian ethos
and he he gave this lecture about
competing ideologies he said look
i'll give you an example we talked about
this competing ideology often you've got
the christian view of the world where
we've got you know
of human nature where man is body and
soul and you've got the transgender view
of human nature which is that
man is really just his soul and his body
is evil when his body doesn't accord
with his soul and his body has to be
mutilated to better accord with it okay
two totally different views and he says
these are competing ideologies and we we
just have to be respectful of them
now he's a little nicer than i am i
don't think that we need to i think we
should be respectful of people but i
don't think we should be respectful of
bad ideas i think this
gnostic idea that my my body has nothing
to do with my
actual identity is ridiculous and we
should ignore it and we should
say it's not true and not teach it
because when you put these things on
equal ground
you empower very bad ideas and when you
empower these bad ideas
they tend not to be happy to leave it at
just a sort of nice liberal tolerance
they want to dominate
because ideologies make truth claims
right they say this is the way the world
is and anything that
does not jive with that they're going to
try to get rid of so
this guy gives his his talk the trent
college here the allegedly christian
college invites a group called
educate and celebrate to make their
school more
quote lgbt friendly educate and
celebrate this non-profit
declare that the school's mission is to
embed gender gender identity and sexual
orientation into the fabric of your
school
so if you do this if you are a christian
school and you invite
this group educate and celebrate what an
orwellian bizarre creepy vague name if
you invite them to your school
they're going to embed gender ideology
in your school and what that is going
what that decision amounts to
is de-christianizing your school you
used to have a christian school
now you have a gender ideology school
okay that's just if you're going to make
that decision as the president of the
school that's what you're going to get
the head of the charity dr ellie barnes
says that the purpose of educate and
celebrate is to quote
completely smash heteronormativity
that's what we want to do so that's it
the christian school invites in this
radical group
to destroy the christian vision of the
school
fair enough that's the school if they
want to do it
you know the problem here is also that
the church of england has just
completely cracked up over the last
50 years or so i i once had a former
anglican who became a catholic tell me
that to join the church of england now
and to to become ordained in the church
of england is not just to rearrange the
deck chairs on the titanic it's to
actually grab and hold on as the thing
goes all the way down
to the bottom and so this poor guy
reverend dr bernard randall
is asks this question
he says or rather he makes this point he
says when ideologies compete we should
respect everybody
okay but one should no more
be required to accept lgbt ideology then
you should be
told that you're in favor of brexit or
that you must be muslim
we would object to that right i made
this point i think on the show yesterday
i made this point somewhere
i don't know you may have heard it
somewhere which is
if a muslim comes out and quotes the
quran
then a homosexual or transvestite
might rightly object that they are being
victimized on the basis of their
sexual orientation or gender identity
right because
the quran has strong things to say
about those sorts of identities and
behaviors but
if the transvestite
criticizes the muslim for quoting the
quran then the muslim
could complain on the basis of being
victimized for his
religion you've got these competing
ideologies here
and which which do we give
the the greater latitude toward that's
the question that people are grappling
with right now and it would appear
that the the answer is on the radical
sex front
because what what happened to this guy's
he didn't just get fired
but he ends up being reported to a
terror watch list
that is aimed at protecting youth
against radicalization
so right now
apply to the american context drag queen
story hour
you know you've got you've got radical
gender ideologues indoctrinating
your toddlers into how to twerk and how
to make little boys look like little
girls
that is considered mainstream in the
culture
christianity is considered radical and
there are now government programs in the
united kingdom
to watch out for this sort of thing he
ultimately was not
permanently listed as a terrorist but he
was reported it shows you where the
perception is
among the people there all right that
was a fun
wait a second don't nope not just yet
ring that bell subscribe make sure you
get notifications
i can't believe i almost got out of this
chair without you have to do it
or you won't be able to see our videos
see you next time
you